why do you why do you think you're an 11
if like being at 10 is you're perfect
so do you do you think you're perfect
no i think there's beauty
in imperfection
you know perfection is not uh why are
you talking over me there's glamorous
beauty and there's a difference anywhere
just got chill okay i believe that i'm
an 11 out of 10 just because i can and
i'm allowed to yeah that way and i
genuinely believe
i was not done talking um i genuinely
believe that perfection is not real but
there's beauty and imperfection and i
think no like you're you're you're very
attractive like i think you're like i
think you're attractive
but no no
but wait
so what i'm saying like like to me i
would never say i'm a 10 because like a
10 is like perfect and i don't think i'm
perfect so i get like is that
but we were saying looks wise right yeah
and i genuinely see myself as genuinely
beautiful i genuinely see myself as
someone who is a goddess because at the
end of the day
society is what decides on
beauty standards right right and i can i
don't have to follow that beauty
standard right i genuinely believe that
i'm beautiful yeah well and i'm not
taking that away from you i just like i
just couldn't i just couldn't i just
could never say like i wouldn't say
you're perfect
like genuinely i feel like i'm a 10 out
of 10. yeah i take care of myself what
has given you that uh my looks
we were only talking about look we
weren't talking about personality or
skill or anything like that is is that
based on the way people have treated you
throughout your life no this is based on
how i was raised and how i view myself
and how i've worked hard to see the
beauty that i deserve to see
so you
so you see an 11 out of 10 beauty i
wouldn't bro it's a joke
okay okay but we could say i'm saying
10. yeah yeah like i just said i
consider myself a 10 out of 10. for sure
so you think you're up there with so who
would you see in like the media that's
like a 10 out of 10 women why are we
going based off of media people no like
why does that matter well because
on society's beauty standards and what
they think about 10 out of 10. well
because like society's beauty i don't
give a [ __ ] about society that's the key
here is that i i have my own viewpoint
right like okay so who would you classes
are 10 out of 10
apart from yourself
well because like it really in order in
order to scale someone 1 to 10 someone
has to not be a 10. right so so like
fully agree with that yeah and so
but we asked
what i think i am what she thinks is
what you think you are i'm not going
based off of anybody else except for
what i see in the mirror right so but
then like that almost wouldn't be a
scale
that like because then you have no way
to mess with [ __ ] right okay so it's
like your way of rebelling against the
scale almost forget rebellion it's just
genuinely how i feel right and i'm not
saying like i like again like i think i
think you're beautiful yeah but it's
just but it's beautiful too it's just
for you to say that you're a five out of
ten right but i just think i live like
in greece
you compare her to you because you're
trying to i'm not making a comparison
in her own right she is beautiful she
would say she's a tendon yes but like
you're in her own right but i just think
if i was if i was a 10 i would have had
modeling
sorry
[Music]
i would have had modeling contracts by
now i would have had people i would have
had results to show that i would have
had nfl nba players but remember that is
all based on beauty standards that are
set by that's based on reality i do like
that's society that's reality
and like but i don't see the same way
that other people do though yeah let me
ask you a question do you think there's
an objective beauty standard yes
can you describe objective to me as in
like what the baseline okay something
like an objective society beauty
standards so for example art is there
good art or is all art the same
i feel like that's kind of different
because art art is also something that's
all about perspective
subjective yeah it's subjective yeah but
in in
in
if you look at medieval buildings
especially americans notice this when
they come here they love our ancient
architecture right compared to their
style architecture there is a standard
and like a stick figure versus like
picasso
i guess um when it comes to that
you know art is something that you put
time and skill and detail into
i can't really say the same for people
my point is that as as generally human
beings can identify what's beauty and
what's not
in the society yeah but even the society
has a standard of beauty yeah exactly
yeah because we can identify a good
architect a good
uh beautiful building than a standard
one yeah we will our brain and we do the
same with beauty yes exactly again
that's just what we consider
aesthetically pleasing like
when it comes to people i can't really
do that because but you can do it to
yourself though we can choose how we
build a building but we can't choose how
we look that much we can only do so much
to our appearance to change ourselves
and then into the and fit into the
beauty standards on top of the fact that
the beauty standard has changed so much
over the last i want to say
disagree
agree with that because you look at the
kings and when they had all their
concubines you can definitely guarantee
you had to be the finest women in the
land be the king's concubine being part
of the king's court age so there had to
there's always been
a whether we like it or not an objective
standard that this man of power
i think the reason for this conversation
like myself in india having is that
there seems to be in these days and
times a
female delusion
about
how
you view yourself and i think men
generally are a little bit more
realistic as the way they view
themselves okay now my question is why
are men so obsessed with humbling women
why is it why does it hurt so much to
watch a woman love themselves and
genuinely believe that they're 10 out of
10 even though they're not according to
society's standards i'll give you an
answer to that one i think it's more of
a reaction because they've tried to do
the simpish behavior be the nice guy and
they're just being flawed for it so
they're overreacting to it that's
probably what's happening i don't think
it's that i think that when you interact
with people right
you generally try to gauge the type of
person that they are right
and so
people can engage me and say oh this
guy's a little bit sarcastic this guy's
this guy yeah
and i get that do you know what i'm
saying but when i engage other people i
too
try to gauge the way in which they see
themselves like oh that person's a
little bit then that person's a little
bit whatever it is right
and too many times in these days and
times when people are engaging in with
people they're saying ah
she thinks that she's all that
well do you know what i mean like women
generally tend to think that they are
higher right than other people and it's
like well can't just calm down a little
bit but that's that's
egotistical versus just confidence i
think what it is i think it has to be if
you have a
actually really illusion i actually
really want to hear what you probably
have to say real quick
question for you
so if you if you um if you had a guy
coming around and saying like
i'm
like a 10 in terms of my income so in
terms of like like i get money i get
this bread
even though he's like broke would you
would you would you not would you not
like look at him like a little
delusional
i probably would but that's because we
can actually gauge that properly right
right
right
remember beautifully
but wealth we can actually measure
properly due to i'm not done talking
damn
we can't properly get we can properly
gauge wealth though according to the
living standards of whatever state or
country we live in well could you argue
and say that if a [ __ ] got two
dollars in his bank account he says he's
a 10 out of 10 i'm gonna be like
that can i argue it's not society that's
saying that two dollars ain't a
millionaire could
actually are able to put a value on that
but we
as a society do not do not have a right
to put a gauge on beauty but they do
cheska but no that's [ __ ] i never
said that there was anything wrong with
that at the end of the day i'm just
saying that i can't i don't see it like
that
that's why i'm saying like i feel like
like when you say that it's not that
because you actually think you're
perfect it's because it's because you
think like you don't like society's like
beauty standards and it's kind of like
your way of rebelling i think i'm
beautiful but then people like you are
christians question me on it
and the only way that i can answer is
the way that they can understand
because when i start saying like because
i think i'm beautiful but they're like
why
why why do you think you're a 10 out of
10. what is it that makes you out of 10
out of 10. and it's like
well but like the thing is like it's
weird though because i feel like girls
do this to guys all the time like i
think if also i think that girls like if
a guy says oh i can get girls i can get
[ __ ]
and like we don't think he can we'll
humble him
and it's kind of like we will that's
what i'm saying like even even even you
kind of like we're trying to do that to
sarah earlier
it's a double standard i think it was a
little selected
but men are not like it was a little
outlandish for him to ask me what i rate
him because at the end of the day i was
talking to you
all right what'd you rate me would you
rate me i think you're allowed to
believe whatever you want to play no no
no right now
greet each other write each other rate
each other oh jesus go rate each other
okay
rate each other
she's thinking i don't want to give him
too much gas
she's trying to go through the whole
thing going so go on jessica
my neck hurts
please
all right
you mm-hmm for your age mm-hmm
no no no no no i'm an eight okay cool
okay
now rate her
chip five really you give her a five now
i'm joking i just went to bed
i can't get mad at you you're an eight
you're you're an eight okay but
genuinely you're not you're not an 11.
i'm trying to speak
i genuinely cannot get upset at the way
that other people feel about my physical
ability
i'm not done talking
oh my goodness maybe put down the
alcohol for a good minute
anyway i genuinely can't get upset when
other people feel the way that they do
about my appearance whether they think
i'm a one or a ten because beauty is in
the eye of the beholder
like for me it's like facial symmetry so
i actually like agree with what he gave
you like i would probably give you seven
eight because your face is very
symmetrical okay and i bet like you
probably had a modeling contract at some
point i
i was a freelance model i haven't um
that's what i'm saying because like i
rate people eight to ten and you could
get a model i i don't really give seven
so i think like if you could i don't i
try not to because i like it's based on
someone else came up with this but like
i just thought it made sense so like
eight to ten is like you could make
money off your looks five six you can't
that's why i don't give myself above a
set like above a six that's why i say
five six because i feel like i'm more
pretty cute yeah you could be a sixth
girl
a lot of modeling agencies have been
looking for people with more distinct
features right even a little less
symmetry than usual especially within
the last like for women though for women
though no not even because um like i do
a lot of research on this because i do
want to model um but i have to be very
careful about what modeling agency that
i do go into because they have to be
inclusive enough and open-minded enough
now if you look at um a lot of the top
modeling agencies like four models or
wilhelmina you're going to see like the
same beauty standard that we've seen for
the last like 10 to 15 years right like
usually the women have long hair
you know the face is very symmetrical
they might have like olive skin or
lighter skin
and you might only see like one or two
dark-skinned models you know um you're
gonna usually see the same things but
now new age modeling agencies are going
for a different beauty standard where
people have a little bit more of an
alternative look which is what i i would
say i'm closer to having an alternative
look so you'll see people more with like
gap teeth or like crooked teeth you'll
see people with like maybe an eye like
that's a little lower than the other
vitiligo you'll see the piercings more
tattoos all that kind of stuff
but like my point is i think that's more
like marketing to women i don't think
that's actually like like i i just feel
like we all know who's attractive like
when someone walks into a room like i
could tell you if they're attractive or
not i think everyone's gonna generally
have the same idea so no matter how much
political correct modeling is out there
generally if you're looking for the
audience that you're targeting they're
gonna they're gonna decipher that they
may tell you it's like oh she's
beautiful in front of their men but deep
down i mean people put lizzo up on a
like pedestal like oh my god she's
amazing it's like
she's just a fat woman
i have to say and i don't even think
it's like humbling like like like you
because you'll say why are you so
obsessed with humbling women right and
like even with lizzo that's what the man
of spheres like favorite person to
humble is i think
and but like it's like sad to her
because like honestly i think she looks
kind of dumb sometimes because people
allow her to like live in this delusion
where she's like walking at 300 pounds
with her butt out and nobody like checks
her
like you don't you don't think that's
kind of messed up
personally like i said i think everybody
that's where delusion comes in i think
everybody has a right to believe that
they are beautiful in their own right
because at the end of the day we can't
really do much to change our looks and
even if we do it's like a damned if you
do damned if you don't kind of society
like if we could get
all liposuction done in our face done
and reconstructed but people are still
gonna find something wrong right when it
came to lizzo right like i
was upset when she did do the whole like
when she like was courtside at the nba
game and like her ass was out right
not because of her size or who she is as
a person or whatever i was more so upset
because that was not the time to do that
like right the kids be watching
basketball too you know like this this
was inappropriate if she was doing it at
her own concert at her own leisure we
can't say much because at the end of the
day that's what she wants well i mean
it's okay if she wants to do that i just
think like
people like their li like the people
around her are lying to her and gassing
her up like we're friends right so i
would if we went out to a bar and i was
and i wore something where like i just
it makes me look heavy
right i and you don't say anything to me
like are you a real friend yeah but
see but that's the difference though is
the
personal relationship versus just people
on the internet that like to idealize
and idolize celebrities
they like to have someone to look up to
and unfortunately
women get to be delusional do you not
understand that they get to be like they
get to be lizzle well i think men don't
get to be that delusional exactly
because like because women were like
yeah girl you go ahead listen as a guy
if you came out and
guys will check other guys say bro like
yeah bro yeah you got a bug in your nose
bro you know what i'm saying like just
get rid of women
ten and i said this on your show before
women will lie to other women
knowing that they're lying to other
women and gas that woman up like lizzo
and then she'll be out in the public eye
and then she'll be like oh i want a high
value man it's like
bro like love you're about 300 pounds
right he's not looking for you right you
know he's not looking for a woman like
you and you might believe that you are
this 11 out of 10 woman right well
but you're not well and it's and to me
like i'm just someone like i'd rather
someone be honest and i think like your
point is like you think like women
should be confident because we can't
always change how we look yeah and so i
think that's like the point like that
women are like really trying to get
across exactly but like like men are
like it's okay to be confident but
like you guys are delusional at some
point and i think there's somewhere in
like a middle ground where you can still
be confident in what you have you know
what i mean but again like that still
brings it back to beauty standards right
like there's a couple of countries in
the world where they believe women who
are fat are the most beautiful yes like
they fully believe that because um i
can't remember the name of the country
literally like that's the thing like
beauty standard really is something
that's created by society like
at some point um
you know like we only saw women with
fairer skin blonde hair blue eyes as the
beauty standard for a long time
but then why but then why delude
yourself about the society in which you
live in you don't live in that society
where women
are who are fat yeah are the beauty
standards you don't live in that society
you live just because i don't live in it
doesn't mean i can't acknowledge it no
no i acknowledge it too but that's my
point is that we live in a society where
there is
that
that's a beauty standard that is proof
that beauty standards really are just
created
they're subjective i get it exactly but
the one in which you live in like lizzo
she's convinced herself that she is a uh
whatever and it's like in this society's
beauty standards you ain't that my dear
and so why do people start gassing her
up saying no you are that and it's like
you are literally feeding because why
are you allowed to say that she's not
because you allowed to humble a man
right if a man bro i never said i was
allowed to do a little bit about women
and men yeah women are allowed i don't
believe i don't believe any of us have a
right to humble anybody at the end of
the day because we are all
we are all just human and we are all
living life we're just trying to figure
it out i just think it's like a reality
man like that's not honestly i just
think it's like real like i'd rather
but your reality is different from mine
but you guys keep forgetting perception
of everything in this world like there's
a reason why i study psychology
everything is perception you guys feel
like reality is no this person is
unattractive and this person is
attractive and this is the beauty
standard that we set
but there's hell of countries and people
out there that do not
who's more attractive lizzo
or
beyonce yeah
but do you see how that is still a
subjective question no matter how you
put it but i i don't think it is i think
they're both beautiful in their own
right because they're asking based on
society's perception
a majority of people say that beyonce is
more beautiful therefore i should say
beyonce right i would say the best
answer for this from a biblical
perspective we're beautiful in the sense
that we are created in the image of god
from a horizontal perspective how god
sees human beings but also you have to
bear in mind how do we see each other
from the um not from the vertical
but from the horizontal yeah men to men
that's where i would say so vertically
how god sees us yes i agree with you we
are beautiful because well god's
creation created in his image but the
horizontal from man to man will differ
and i will agree and you have to agree
that there is
nine times out of ten down to
probability there will be a standard
yeah but that's because we create it and
that doesn't mean that i'm gonna go
against it and bark about it and cry
about it no i i'm fully aware that we
have a standard but
because i have unpacked that in my own
mind right because i used to be somebody
that wanted to try and fit the beauty
standard so bad when i was in high
school right i had very long black hair
it was down my back yeah um i made sure
i didn't put on any makeup because i
wanted to be naturally beautiful as
natural as possible you know like i did
all these little things to fit that and
then i realized
beauty is not just one way it's not like
a
i'll agree beauty is a combination it's
a holistic thing
but i think your look like brings you up
or down like okay
you have a type i have a type right and
i think if a guy fits that type he'll
maybe go up or down like one point but i
don't think you can like go from like a
five to ten i just think like and i
think you ask 99 of people who's more
attractive liz or beyonce they're gonna
say the same thing and like but this is
what i always say like whenever people
like don't really have a good argument
they always look for exceptions to the
rule and like the exception to the rules
that random country in africa yeah like
but just the fact that the exception
exists tells you that
it is really something that we create in
our own minds but even in africa well
from nigeria there was a demand for
ferrous uh women
i've never felt more attractive in my
life than when i went to india oh my god
they would love you they loved me they
were asking for pictures ever i was like
me
it's like the same when i went to
lebanon
i went to lebanon with like and they
were like i was like the only black
person in lebanon it's like oh my god
mike tyson
okay
i gotta read some